vous savez on nous impose actuellement
des exigences en demandant que les
médecins de l'hôpital d'omsk présente
immédiatement leur avis médicaux qu'on
mène une enquête quant au fait que
navalni est tombé dans le coma
souvenez-vous il a passé un peu plus de
24 heures à omsk et tous nos collègues
occidentaux ont fait du bruit en
demandant pourquoi il n'y avait aucune
information et voilà cela fait déjà une
semaine qu'il est en allemagne
les médecins allemands non plus ne
fournissent aucune information il faut
donc davantage de temps mais pour une
quelconque raison personne n'exige rien
de personne ne les juge pour leur
tentative de cacher la vérité
on nous accuse de ne pas enquêter sur
cette situation
ce n'est pas vrai dès le jour de
l'incident le ministre russe de
l'intérieur a lancé des investigations
préliminaires et l' enquête pourra
commencer
quand on aura établi ce qui s'est
produit et je le dis une fois de plus
pour le moment ce n'est pas clair